curité madame monsieur bonsoir kahn voit
ce soir le sacre de la reine margot
isabelle adjani a été toute cette
journée la reine de la croisette avant
de monter il ya quelques instants les
fameuses marches du palais en compagnie
de son metteur en scène patrice chéreau
il y a des jours les éléments se
déchaînent à croire que l'attendent une
star et lectrices même l'atmosphère
depuis l'ouverture tout le festival
l'attendait la voici enfin isabelle
adjani la reine margot mise en scène par
patrice chéreau du théâtre il reste
l'esprit de troupe
voici l'équipe du film daniel auteuil
jean hugues anglade virna lisi vincent
perez miguel bosé que du bonheur mais
poussez vous qu'on puisse les voir
derrière les acclamations il ya bien sûr
un film est surtout un rôle pour
isabelle adjani participer la vision le
traitement qu'ils voulaient faire de ce
moment précis de l'histoire de france
pour raisons qui vous expliquer tout à
l'heure c'était tout ce qu'elle reflète
dans notre histoire
aujourd'hui l'histoire de nos sociétés
aujourd'hui et il y avait
évidemment pour une actrice
impossibilité de d'être
cette belle d'être amoureuse des
passionnés d'être malheureuse c'est à
dire tous les sentiments concours
recherche dans un rôle ce soir la
réunion s'en remet à deux jugements
celui du jury mais aussi celui du public
car rassurez vous monsieur vous pourrez
la voir le film est sorti aujourd'hui en
salles